réhabilitation et rénovation des
collèges une priorité budgétaire pour le
département des yvelines
la collectivité va investir 430 millions
d'euros jusqu'en 2020 plusieurs
établissements sont concernés comme les
collège paul eluard de guyancourt en
reconstruction et albert einstein de
magny les hameaux en restructuration
nous avions un certain nombre d'endroits
où les conditions d'enseignement étaient
pas très bonne je veux pas dire dégradé
le monstre est exagéré mais pas très
bonne votre réforme en cours la
restauration scolaire avec une
tarification unique basé sur les revenus
et la composition des familles appliqué
à partir du 1er janvier 2019 faisant
cette unification tarifaire il nous
paraît nécessaire d'avoir une
unification de la fabrication pour avoir
une homogénéisation de la qualité la
question des circuits courts aussi donc
des produits disponibles
on va essayer de d'avoir une
saisonnalité des produits d unification
rendue possible par la création d'une
société d'économie mixte à opération
unique les yvelines s'associer à un
opérateur privé pour fournir les
quelques 48 mille repas par jour dans
les collèges le département en tant
qu'institution présidera le conseil
d'administration on surveillera cette
société pour s'assurer que la qualité
l'écoutent
tout choix bien cadré est bien conforme
au cahier des charges
le conseil départemental désignera le
prestataire privé lors de la séance
prévue le vendredi 28 septembre prochain